Matt Ryan on pardon my take earlier this
week a candid Matt Ryan uh yeah you
gotta you got a good way getting people
to loosen up it's almost like they
forget that their words are being
recorded to be played later because he
could get any new it you know he could
get roasted for tea said yeah we're
gonna win twelve games yeah I'm the best
quarterback in the division although in
fairness he is the best quarterback
right now in the division we talked
earlier this week about how with all the
obsession about the Buccaneers in the
Saints and they play week one and Tom
Brady and Drew Brees combined age of 84
future Hall of Famers Matt Ryan is still
pretty damn good and the Falcons
finished strong last year six and two
after starting one in seven just like
the Jets did they're one of those teams
that we should be pointing at saying we
need to keep an eye on them and Matt
Ryan already 10th all-time on the
passing yardage list 11th on the passing
touchdown list he's got plenty of gas
left in the tank he's gonna keep
climbing that ladder we just kind of
wrote the Falcons off after they blew
the 28 to 3 lead in Super Bowl 51 they
continue to exist they continue to have
Julio Jones they continue to have Matt
Ryan they continue to have great players
and they are a team that I think they
should be concerned about in the NFC
South absolutely absolutely had a lot of
injuries obviously on defense last year
that kind of derailed the start of their
season but they played wellness in the
back half of the season they showed some
life they went remember they went out to
San Francisco and won against the 49ers
they beat the Saints I you know Matt
Ryan is one I was and I don't mean this
in a bad way I was shocked with how
great that interview was and how you
know likeable and open Matt Ryan was I
just didn't know that you know you watch
these guys for a really long time and
you don't really have a sense of their
personality and then we had Matt Ryan on
for 30 minutes and I was like Matt
Ryan's awesome he's awesome to talk to
so it was a lot of fun to have him on
and Mike you're you're right Matt Ryan
he is you know up there with the most
underrated quarterbacks in the NFL if
you look at his career I went back and I
looked at it you know he came in the
league in 2008 since 2008 there has only
been one
my ride has finished out of the top ten
in qbr and that was 11 he finished 11th
so he you know and he's been one three
nine yo five like he has been a top 10
quarterback consistently for a decade
now and it's crazy that we kind of just
forget about Matt Ryan because when you
say that when you talk about longevity
you talk about you know having the
consistent great you know seasons top
ten seasons that's what every franchise
is looking for and when we make our list
Matt Ryan is sort of passed over because
he's just not a name that you think of
and we actually talked to him about that
and it really is and it's stupid for us
as fans and analysts and whatever you
want to call myself it's stupid what we
do that it basically just comes down to
did you win a Super Bowl or did you not
if Matt Ryan won the Super Bowl if they
23 never happens we're saying Matt Ryan
with Russell Wilson with Patrick mahomes
with Aaron Rodgers with Tom Brady we are
absolutely doing that it's so so dumb
that that one single you know the two
quarters you know preclude us from
putting him in that top echelon of
quarterbacks and take it a step farther
it's almost as if that that loss in the
Super Bowl after they were up 28 to 3
disqualifies him from any future
consideration it's like he never existed
like go away you're done you had your
chance and there he is at number 7 on
the Chris Sims top 40 quarterback
countdown that surprised a lot of people
it shouldn't have
what should surprised people if you're
listening to us and thinking about ways
maybe you could make a little extra
discretionary income Matt Ryan plus 44
hundred on the MVP odds plus 44 hundred
look I'm not saying that that he's in
the three or four finalists in my mind
but at plus forty four hundred that's
awfully intriguing plus forty four
hundred is intriguing the the Falcons
have ten out of eleven starters on
offense or first-round picks and I know
people will say well a first-round pick
doesn't really mean anything after a
first-round pick Oh contraire I always
think a first-round pick Kevin white if
they get Kevin white I'll think that
he's going to be great because if you
were four
around talent your first round talent
for life and yeah I think the Falcons
away they finished last season they're
gonna be a team that is gonna be in the
mix this year and Matt Ryan if that
really is kind of the recipe right if
the Falcons are in the playoff picture
Matt Ryan will be in the MVP discussion
and I think this year it's going to be
even more clear and simple than ever
before with seven teams per conference
making the postseason only one team will
earn a bye per conference I think the
MVP barring some sort of historic
performance by someone from one of the
other teams the MVP is going to be more
likely than not the quarterback of one
of the two number one seeds so if the
Falcons find a way to defy expectations
catch people napping win 12 games is
Matt Ryan guaranteed to you and my
Internet's son PFT commenter they're in
position to be the 1 seed and and also
if they do play at that level that means
Matt Ryan is necessarily gonna have a
strong statistical year and they could
sail over that seven and a half
over/under win total and maybe end up
the 1 seed and then Matt Ryan maybe ends
up a lot of people to cash the ticket at
plus 4400 I'm looking right now at the
Falcons schedule it's not easy there's
you know they stay open with with the
Seahawks and then going to the Cowboys
those aren't gonna be easy games but uh
you know I I just think especially the
Dan Quinn thing was fascinating to me
last year Mike because they really you
rarely do see that where a team truly
does play for their coach's job and the
guy ends up keeping his job I don't know
if that's a good thing or a bad thing
cuz you know I think Dan Quinn is a fine
coach I don't think he's a great head
coach but he's a good coach and that
locker room coming together and not
quitting on the season it doesn't matter
for this year I don't know I mean III
tend to think that it would but who
knows so the four starting quarterbacks
in the NFC South are Drew Brees Tom
Brady Matt Ryan and Teddy Bridgewater
they also have Taysom Hill and Jameis
Winston floating around in the division
who is the best quarterback in the
division right now I noticed that you
just said tasted Hill before Jameis
Winston which is
utterly ridiculous cuz Jameis Winston is
a future hall-of-famer and he is a
starter or something that Jason Hill has
never done the best quarterback in the
NFC South I'll rank them I think it's
still Tom Brady one Matt Ryan to Drew
Brees three Jameis Winston for Teddy
Bridgewater five Taysom Hill six yeah
I'm gonna go Matt Ryan number one I am I
agree with him I think that the the the
one thing that we are not looking at
with Tom Brady is the fact that he is
gonna be 43 in just a few weeks father
time is undefeated and no amount of
avocado ice cream has got stave that off
and I think this is the young we start
to see we really start to see the mighty
no one forgets that Tom Brady is 43
years old no one forgets that Tom Brady
is right now but everyone people
assuming he planned an eye-level
indefinitely but guess what if you
started assuming then and it's homme
Brady could keep playing at a high level
indefinitely when he was aged 37 you
would have been right six years in a row
so yeah you could be the guy who says
this is the year that he falls off a
cliff but again he's done it every
single year so I'm not gonna be that guy
but at some point he's going to fall off
the cliff cliff is coming years ago I'm
saying it this year I'm saying when
you're throwing this is my first time
saying it I don't know but I'm saying
that that it's telling to me that the
Patriots decided to go with Jared
Stidham over Tom Brady and through this
process of doing the Chris Sims top 40
countdown we looked at film of Stidham
from training preseason last year and I
know that's not as relevant as as
regular-season real live game footage
would be but there's some promise there
and the system is what it is and I think
the bill Belleville check out to the
point where he he just decided that yeah
it's coming get rid of him one year too
early instead of one year too late and
they moved on and it could be that the
Bucks are inheriting the one year too
late Tom Brady all I'm saying is and
that that I'm not saying these
wurst I'm just saying he's not the best
I'm saying Matt Ryan is going to be
better than him and maybe Brady will be
number two but I just think the ability
to be at that highest possible level
it's not there anymore and and maybe
he's out there defying the NFLPA to
prove us all wrong and maybe that's why
he's willing to risk getting and
transmitting the virus but I think that
at a minimum he at a minimum he's not
the best quarterback in the division
where he falls after that remains to be
seen
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports